today's one minute monday is be real i
recently wrote a newsletter about how
i was up late one night because a new
baseball game came out a computer game
that i i was waiting for i wanted to
play it and so i i it finally came out i
downloaded it i played it and i looked
up at the clock and it was three in the
morning like i got to get the bed the
next one i woke up was eleven o'clock
and i felt frustrated angry depressed
and had you know guilty that i wasted so
much time playing this game the night
before and i had to find a way to turn
my day around and i sent this out to my
newsletter list and and people wrote
back and one in particular his name was
jeremy said evan i love how real and
open and honest you are in your emails
this is
this is important because if you want to
connect with people if you want people
to understand your message you want
people to buy from you if you want
people to feel like they know you like
you trust you build a relationship with
you then you have to be real
tell them real stories you are not
perfect that's okay that's what's going
to make people attracted to you nobody
wants to deal with the perfect person so
yeah i make mistakes and i talk about it
and i also have big wins and i talk
about that but everything i talk about
is real it's human it makes a connection
and that's what draws people in because
people watch these videos i read my
newsletters they feel like they know me
they like me they trust me even though i
may have no idea who you are you guys
feel like you know me because i'm
telling real stories so be real when
you're real people will buy more from
you they'll connect with you better and
they'll help you start your movement
believe those are watching like the
video thumbs up below leave a comment
let me know what you think and subscribe
to the channel by clicking my face i'll
see you soon